superintendent dr jesus jarrah delivered
his state of the schools address this
morning this year's theme is emerging
stronger together mary jane belliesa was
there and she joins us live from
caesar's palace where the event took
place with what he wants the district to
concentrate on moving forward mary jane
dr jesus jarrah highlights many key
points including a plan to outline and
improve school efficiency curb violence
in schools and ways to support teachers
and students
dr jarrah discussed how to move
education forward citing the community
needs to hold the district accountable
to ensure the plan moves in the right
direction we have to support our schools
our teachers and at the professional
learning our leaders are doing a great
job and really building that
instructional leadership how do we
monitor instruction how do we monitor
support dr jarrah also addressed violent
incidents on campuses he wants to make
sure teachers get support in the
classroom to feel safe he also addressed
students that had been expelled and
disciplinary policies we presented to
the board last night
on our
our school justice partnership and all
our discipline
from day one i've said you know i don't
tolerate
the violence
but we can just throw kids out in the
street another goal hire more than
sixteen hundred teachers in one year
with recruiting not only in state but
out of state too it's one of those reach
goals that my hr team the 25 percent
we're going to double down we need them
now dr jarrah plans to also focus on
mental and emotional health for students
and staff reversing the pandemic impacts
on the district as well as having better
expectations moving forward reporting
from caesar's palace mary jane valleja
live local now